Samsung's operating profits are falling
off a cliff over the past year their
quarterly profits have plummeted from
just over $10 billion down to just $490
million this represents a 95% cliff dive
within just a matter of a year and it's
the lowest numbers that Samsung has
reported since 2009 normally this would
be indicative of a failing company like
Nokia or Yahoo whose numbers are down
across the board but that's not quite
the case with Samsung take their Topline
numbers for example this too is down for
Samsung from 240 billion per year down
to 200 billion per year but that's a
much more modest drop of about 16% as
opposed to
95% a similar story can be seen with
their smartphone shipments as well while
they have been slowly bleeding dominance
in sales nothing drastic has unfolded
within the past 12 to 24 months this
puts Samsung in a really weird situation
where they're not exactly losing
relevance but they are losing
profitability it's easy to write this
off as just a market downturn but when
we peel back the layers it becomes clear
that Samsung is facing a much larger
crisis due to the era of peak smartphone
so join me as we dive deeper into
Samsung's existential crisis and their
struggle to remain
[Music]
profitable speaking of a struggle to
remain profitable many investors are
struggling to remain profitable in this
era of high inflation and high interest
rates more than ever people are hoarding
cash in savings accounts and brokerage
accounts to earn as much interest as
possible which is by no means a bad
strategy but it won't last forever when
the FED starts cutting rates savings
account interest will naturally follow
suit one way to overcome this decline
however is to take advantage of bonds
with bonds you can lock in current High
interest rates for not just the next 6
to 12 months but for as long as 30 years
if that sounds enticing please consider
checking out our upcoming Bond investing
app Silo in the description below but
anyway a simple Google search would tell
you that the primary culprit behind
Samsung's dwindling profits is the
memory chip Market if you didn't know
Samsung is not just a big memory chip
producer but the biggest memory chip
producer this title definitely sounds
impressive on paper but Samsung actually
has had to make massive sacrifices to
get here like over betting on the chip
Market you see one of the ways that
Samsung was able to beat the competition
and rise to the top was by simply
outspending the competition in fact
they've been doing this for decades
dating as far back as 1997 in 1997
Samsung opened up a $1.3 billion memory
chip Fab in Austin Texas over the next
14 years this would grow into being a $9
billion investment which is not only one
of the largest chip invest investments
in the world but one of the largest
foreign investments the US has ever seen
this sort of spending is what allowed
Samsung to catch up to and overtake the
competition but this is also a very
dangerous game because there is no moat
when it comes to internal components
most end consumers don't care or even
know what brand of chips is going into
their smartphones and computers and cars
so there's virtually no brand loyalty
and companies like apple just go with
whoever is offering the best performance
and price at the time over the past
decade this has very much been Samsung
but it doesn't take long to fall behind
within the chip industry mors law may or
may not be dead but one thing is for
sure chips are still advancing extremely
fast even stagnating for an year or two
could destroy the lead that took decades
to build so year after year these chip
producers are having to invest more and
more really all of this is just one
massive game of chicken fortunately for
Samsung they haven't dropped the ball
when it comes to R&D they've actually
been doing the exact opposite they've
been stepping up to the plate but this
has simply resulted in ridiculously
large investments just earlier this year
Samsung announced that they would be
investing wait for it
$228 billion to build the world's
largest chip facility let me put that in
perspective that's more than Apple has
spent on R&D across the entire company
since the launch of the iPhone phone
itself it's hard to find data about
Apple's R&D spending throughout the 80s
and 90s but it's very likely that 228
billion is more than Apple has spent on
R&D throughout their entire history this
honestly isn't that surprising given
that $228 billion is enough money to buy
out a Fortune 50 company cash and
Samsung is looking to spend this much
money on an industry that they could
lose at any time within just a matter of
2 years that is no doubt a gutsy bet but
when you take take a closer look at the
company's internals it starts to become
more clear why Samsung is basically
betting at all it's likely that Samsung
feels that they have no other choice
this is probably a bit confusing because
most of us see Samsung as a giant
conglomerate with strongholds and dozens
of Industries they make everything from
smartphones chips monitors laptops and
TVs to refrigerators dishwashers washing
machines and who knows what else but
while they do indeed have their hands in
every business that you can think of
almost 60% of their entire profits come
from just one sector semiconductors so
it's not surprising why Samsung is
willing to make such a massive gamble
with chip fabrication it's their bread
and butter and they can't afford to lose
but one thing that they're forgetting is
that just because they stay on top of
the chip industry doesn't mean that
they'll actually stay on top overall let
me
explain
if large amounts of capital and a lack
of emote weren't bad enough another
major Pitfall of the chip industry is
that it's one of the most cyclical
Industries in the world and the pandemic
simply exacerbated this I think we all
remember how Tech was a bit hard to come
by back in 2020 and 2021 ps5s and
graphics cards were basically impossible
to come byy often times you had to pay
two to three times the price just to buy
these gadgets and it was was n just Tech
products either anything that even
slightly had to do with chips were
extremely hard to come by including cars
and even refrigerators which often had
waiting times in the 6 to 12 month range
as such all of these products naturally
rocketed in price most people just
figured that these price increases were
due to high inflation but a lot of it
just had to do with the global chip
shortage you see when the pandemic hit
most chip Fabricators either pulled back
or completely shut down temporarily due
to co restrictions and general
uncertainty at the same time the demand
for these products went through the roof
everyone was staying at home meaning
that they were more dependent on
electronics than ever moreover they
weren't spending any money on vacations
or eating out or any of that so they
were able to spend a lot more on Tech
this led to an extreme situation where
there was no Supply and massive demand
leading to ridiculous revenue and profit
margins for chip makers many chipmakers
including Samsung assumed that this was
simply the new Norm for the modern
hybrid economy but it hasn't quite
played out that way in fact prices for
Tech products are very much falling off
a cliff as supply and demand have more
or less normalized take Tesla prices for
example in the peak of the chip shortage
in late 2021 and early 2022 model X
prices reached as high as
$108,000 but over the past 18 months
prices have almost half down to
$63,000 this is great for consumers as
at least some some prices are finally
returning to reality but for Samsung
this is a nightmare in fact normalizing
supply and demand have led to Dam prices
plummeting by 53% year-over-year and
experts don't think the pain is over
either so we could very well be looking
at a 60% plus price drop before things
finally stabilize given that 60% of
Samsung's profits were coming from chips
it's no wonder why their bottom line has
been obliterated profits from their chip
business have not only gone down they've
actually become negative in fact over
the first 6 months of 2023 Samsung took
a $7 billion loss on their chip business
Samsung is of course trying to cut
production to prop up prices as much as
they can but unfortunately demand is
falling even faster you see it's not
just prices that have been plummeting
demand has also been plummeting as
companies and consumers have become much
more conservative with tech spending due
to high inflation and recession fears
not to mention most people just got a
bunch of new tech over the past few
years so they don't exactly feel the
need to upgrade which brings us into our
bigger question will Samsung ever
recover normally the answer would just
be yes eventually when the chip industry
enters another boom cycle Samsung should
naturally recover but here's an
interesting point to consider not all of
the chip industry is getting destroyed
in fact certain sectors within the chip
industry are doing better than ever
specifically AI I don't even think I
need to explain this I mean just take a
look at nvidia's stock graph it's
vertical granted the stock market is
very much being irrational with Nvidia
but it's not like Nvidia is doing bad
fundamentally either in fact they just
posted their largest quarterly profits
of all time coming in at $6 billion of
course Nvidia is an exception who has
largely benefited from the AI boom
everyone focused on traditional chipm
like Samsung tsmc AMD and Intel have
seen their margins get obliterated but
this brings up an even larger question
where exactly does Samsung fit within
this new era of peak smartphone while
it's true that Samsung has made massive
advancements with mobile chips and
memory over the past 15 years a lot of
their success is actually just thanks to
the success of the smartphone industry
at large this was great in the early to
mid-20 when smartphone sales were
exploding but over the past 5 years
smartphone sales have started to fall
quite noticeably and the more time that
passes the more likely it feels that
smartphones are destined for the same
fate as PCS as PC sales started to fall
manufacturers naturally started
competing on price of course there were
some exceptions like apple and some
higher-end product lines from Dell and
Asus but for the most part the PC
industry became a race to the bottom and
profit margins edged closer and closer
to zero many reputable manufacturers
like Sony and Toshiba actually just
exited the business altogether and many
of these survivors like Dell and HP
started focusing on other parts of their
business like the cloud and servers they
simply kept around their laptops and PCs
as a way to maintain their brand
presence as opposed to drive massive
profits this same thing is starting to
happen with smartphone Brands as well in
early 2021 for example LG left the
smartphone business after losing money
for 23 consecutive quarters the same
thing happened to HTC Microsoft and
Nokia as well heck even Apple isn't
immune in fact that's why they stopped
reporting iPhone sales 5 years ago and
with how disappointing the iPhone 15 is
who knows how bad sales will be with
that being said though Apple will do
just fine because they've shifted their
focus to monetizing the use of the
iPhone as opposed to the purchase of the
iPhone the same however cannot be said
about Samsung Samsung phones run Android
meaning that it's mainly Google that
profits from the use of Samsung's 2
billion phones Samsung on the other hand
is still feel very much dependent on the
sales of their own smartphones and other
smartphones for which they make internal
components for and as smartphones become
more and more commoditized this business
will simply become less and less viable
this isn't to say that Samsung is on the
brink of collapse or something but the
point is that this isn't just a downturn
for Samsung rather it's very much a test
regarding whether Samsung can grow and
evolve past smartphones can they
capitalize on the AI Trend can they
shift to monetizing the use of Samsung
phones can they reduce their dependency
on smartphone components these are the
concerns that Samsung will have to
address in the coming years if they want
to grow past the era of peak smartphone
will Samsung be able to make this jump
or will they end up as the next IBM only
time will tell in the meantime if you'd
like to take advantage of high interest
rates and have the government and top
corporations pay you 47% check out our
upcoming Bond investing app Silo in the
description below but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one